and now I'll pass the reins to the chair
of the scientific and Technical Awards
committee Barbara Ford Grant thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
good evening everyone
unlike the Oscars recognizing the year
and Cinema
um the scitec awards are unique in that
they cover achievements that can take a
decade or more of invention refinement
engineering and evolution to be
recognized by the academy
it is only through the countless hours
of research that the awards committee
comes to our award recommendations
we're grateful for the diligent efforts
of the committee the volunteers and the
unwavering support from our Board of
Governors
these technologies have enabled
filmmakers to push their own boundaries
through breathtaking special effects
exquisitely captured Optical images
entirely imagined worlds and characters
all once considered impossible now
create stories more complex more
visually stunning and more accessible to
a global community of storytellers and
audiences alike
and remember it's not just about us
the work we do inspires a whole new
generation of filmmakers and
technologists
tonight we will honor the extraordinary
work by innovators and Engineers whose
contributions have forever changed how
we make and experience Motion Pictures
from advancements in coveted techniques
to the development of Novel and
groundbreaking new methodologies these
individuals have made a lasting impact
on the Art and Science of Cinema
we celebrate their accomplishments and
recognize their hard work and dedication
for some of you the recognition being
dis bestowed tonight is honoring the
culmination of a lifetime of effort
to quote the great Jonathan Ireland our
Academy was created to make art possible
to make the Excellence of the Art and
Science of Cinema possible
and in turn it can and does make the
world a better place and us
better people in it now since all of us
are observant as well as good at
Counting
you may notice we have more honorees in
the room than there are Awards being
handed out tonight that's because some
of you in this room already received
your accolades virtually
take a look back at the 2021 virtual
celebration
hi it's great to join you at this year's
scientific and Technical awards show
in 2021 technical achievement awards
were presented to 42 recipients
for the post-production tracking systems
of Autodesk shotgun
and f-track studio for the Intel Embry
Ray tracing Library thanks a lot to the
academy for honoring our work for the
head mounted camera systems from
standard deviation we were extremely
lucky to work with some of the biggest
directors of our time and techno props
we have a constant stream of high-end
creatives making huge demands on us
we're working with Jim Cameron you know
you don't you don't tell Jim Cameron
though yeah
for the iso Auto calibrating SDR
monitors
for lavalier microphones from DPA
and countrymen Associates
for the hair simulation systems ilm
haircraft Dynamics synapse
Taz
it's amazing to be receiving this award
and such an honor and at Walt Disney
Studios I've wanted to work at the
movies since I was a little kid so this
is it is like a dream come true and
scientific and Engineering awards were
presented to 15 recipients
for the sanken lavalier microphones for
teradek Bolt Wireless video streaming
it's very rare that Engineers or
scientists get recognized for impact
that they had in the world for the
omimon wireless chipset the first
meeting that we ever had when he thought
that there is a need for Wireless on
production set there are technical
Awards in the Oscars and one day you
might receive this award for the word
fit system and vocal line and re-voice
pro being able to cope with an infinite
variety of signals and pitches will
never stop being a challenge it's a
never-ending battle but it's quite a fun
one to continue working on and for the
izotope RX audio processing system as
long as filmmakers continue to push the
boundaries of what they want to do we
will continue to push the limits of our
technology and what we want to do
solving problems that haven't been
solved before
congratulations to all of 2021's
honorees thank you very much this award
means everything to me and to my family
look forward to working with these
friends here in the future
congratulations guys well done thank you
thank you
[Music]
oh oops
I am thrilled some of those recipients
could be with us here tonight
many who have traveled from very far
away could those honorees please stand
up and receive the real-time Applause
you deserve
thank you